[Music]
foreign
it is Thursday May 11th we're here at
Toronto Airport and we're heading to
Dublin Ireland to learn all about
project Striker we're going to see some
very very interesting Tech and I'm
hoping I can get some sleep on the plane
so that I'm feeling nice and fresh
[Music]
yeah
our trip starts in Dublin where in 2022
Raya opened a 20 million dollar
Production Studio as part of project
Striker a new initiative to run Esports
broadcasts all over the world out of
three high-tech super Studios a studio
in Seattle is still under construction
and a third in the asia-pacific region
hasn't been announced so for now Striker
Dublin is the only Studio of its kind in
the world thanks so much to Cisco for
sending me out to Dublin and then to
London to see all of the tech all of the
hard work that goes into producing an
event like MSI I've loved being here
love seeing all the fans this is my
first International League event in my
own home country no less it's been an
absolutely incredible experience yeah so
the thing with Lee for me is that it's
been such a big part of my life for like
10 plus years now and I love it but I
don't really understand how a lot of it
works like it's always amazed me playing
it watching it how does it all come
together I don't understand the ins and
outs of it I thought there would be the
broadcast room and people would be like
yeah it's just over there by the
broadcast room but you try to tell
anyone here it's by the broadcast room
and they'll be like well which one which
floor you know like so I think the main
thing is is like the piece we've
actually been able to design build and
get this up in operation I think Shucks
everyone in the team when somebody says
like how long is Striker operationally
you're like
um it's been less than like kind of 12
months or in around the 12 month Mark
now although there's three events
happening we actually have four control
rooms up so msi's example has not only
got a world feed but it also has the Neo
feed which is our English feed so it's
taking two control rooms up so four out
of the six are actually operational now
it's a real milestone for us to finally
see and be able to touch and kind of
demonstrate that it's working and it's
working well
tomorrow's prefix December red December
to slide around in three two one flat
rate good job but an expensive
Production Studio on its own wouldn't
allow Riot to do everything they wanted
with project Striker a big part of that
magic is a new technology called jpeg XS
so jpeg XS is a Cutting Edge
contribution technology what that
largely comes down to is the speed that
it actually is able to transfer about
their encodes and decodes what that
results in is almost zero latency
between sites so MSI being in London and
Dublin here the latency is almost you
wouldn't notice it jpeg access is the
name of the technology but what Striker
has done differently here is they've
combined that technology with massive
investment from Cisco so they have the
data center in Dublin and their own
network with Riot direct the riot
directors are on global ISP internal
variety and I was in shoes a number of
years ago largely to reduce latency for
players in-game anywhere in the world
when you combine those two together
alongside disco it results in the talent
on site being able to make gameplay
calls without zero latency similar to
the director being able to talk to the
camera people on site and make those
calls as well without you seeing any
kind of delay on broadcast this is all
great because the downside of sending a
signal over IP is that if there's like a
blip in the signal then it's not great
the whole show could go down completely
Riot have invested so much time and
money and people into building this
infrastructure this network that they're
now pretty confident they can rely on it
and so far in the short time they have
been using it there haven't been any
issues
foreign
Dublin yeah we spent a few days at
striker what are your takeaways what are
your final thoughts I can definitely say
now how much this helps your job as a
Caster being able to rely on a system
like this on a network on infrastructure
being able to do your job from anywhere
in the world right and not being
restricted to certain places and certain
times just makes the whole casting
experience 10 times better and obviously
that makes the viewers experience better
right I don't think I'll ever forget the
things I learned you know the last few
days being a product Striker I think
whenever I watch a broadcast now I'm
going to be thinking about all the
different things we've talked about even
little things like seeing The Observers
cut together highlights on the Fly mid
game like that's fully embedded in my
experience of Esports now heading off to
London next and I'm really excited to
see the copper box Arena because like
we've seen so much of it the last few
days if we're not looking at product
Striker we're sat there watching the
games themselves every time it cuts to
the stadium it's like it is incredible
it looks amazing so yeah excited to be
there in Perth awesome
[Music]
all right and we made it to London we
are here at the coffee box arena for MSI
it's exciting I can feel the energy the
crowds are pouring in but I'm most
excited about seeing how project
Strikers technology and all the good
stuff we've looked at so far is helping
casters do their job right here let's
get into it
I'm very fortunate that from the LEC and
from the European perspective when we
first started our studio we actually
started working remotely with the Santa
Monica control room so we used you know
undersea like dark fiber cables and and
our entire show was produced and managed
and streamed from Santa Monica that had
a huge amount of challenges and
Technical problems especially when it
came to delay when the amount of time it
takes the data to go back and forth when
it came to like synchronizing voices
synchronizing the game working here with
Dublin and working just literally half a
second if that between here and and
there it's one of the smoothest
experiences that we've ever had on day
one of our show we had nearly zero Tech
problems and as somebody that's done
this for nearly 10 years it was quite
special it was quite unique for me
specifically as talented as somebody
that's on camera the fact that it was so
smooth it was so seamless it was so easy
is the biggest like success
it's a foreign
thanks to Cisco's Network more than a
petabyte of data was transferred to and
from world 2022. that's more than a
thousand terabytes all with no packet
loss and the final piece of this puzzle
is the production staff here on the
ground some of whom oversee the
broadcast as it goes to Dublin and then
out all over the world from a truck
parked just outside the venue we operate
on a Model similar to the Olympics or
the world's cup or any other major
sporting event that uses a world fee
that we produce wholly within Riot and
that world seed has everything you need
to to cover the sport whether it's
in-game content behind the scenes b-roll
interviews Graphics video packages all
that good stuff in terms of the scale of
our sets and our shows you know we
utilize technology that comes from all
over the world we don't just go
somewhere and get some camera operators
go somewhere and get whatever we find
the people we really want to work with
and if that means investing in people
all around the world that means
investing in technology and Tools around
the world so be it the investment in
Striker and all of our remote production
capabilities are really great because it
allows us to at least centralize some of
that and those efficiencies allow us to
just deliver more and more over time
let's go check out the production truck
we've got cameras in the coaches room
we've got all the face cams we're
operating with about 30 cameras on this
show all of which get sent back to
Striker over Riot direct using jpeg XS
transmission with centralized
storytelling we're able to put the best
of the best of servers on it to make
sure that everyone gets the highest
quality or the best the best graphics
invest in the newest stats and that way
our investments don't just go to the
English feed or the Chinese feed or
whoever may have the biggest budget but
those infrastructure or maybe
geographically close but all the
technology in the world wouldn't matter
without the team of broadcast
professionals operating it all behind
the scenes it's important to highlight
and I don't think it gets highlighted
enough the incredible work that these
teams are doing to passionately create
workflows and passionately create the
tool set that we need to do those shiny
player facing things those people are
real heroes that I think don't get
enough credit because the technology is
shiny is cool and cool and the product
is shiny and cool but the thing in the
middle is really thankless and those
people you know are doing some of the
most incredible work
[Music]
finally made it I feel like I've learned
a lot it is kind of crazy just being
here at the end of the whole trip I hope
that other people watching this will
have an idea about the technology and
the people and the whole operation that
goes into it because that's the thing I
think when you talk about Esports or
League Esports being Global sometimes
you can kind of forget what that really
means it's easy to think oh that just
means it's Global because there's
players all over the world we watch all
over the world but it really is global
and like the most interconnected way
possible it was so so cool seeing these
fans from opposite sides of the world
yes we have those rivalries but in the
day we're all playing the same game and
that really brings it all together
I took for granted how much interacting
with fans how much being in the same
space as fans Not only meant to me but
what impact I had on the broadcast those
connections and that like shared passion
it has literally brought me to tears uh
several times and it's just something
that I sincerely hope continues to grow
and continues to travel around the world
because it's just something that I
absolutely love doing
[Applause]
[Music]
good